this is the function that where did you
see it now there are some questions
there but i'm actually going to ask you
to just look at the function that's all
i wanted you to do to read the question
so we got there and then I'm just going
to pose the question to you graph that's
all really like the different parts of
the way they're leading you through
that's all they really want out of this
okay now this is a fairly sort of
standard way of expression involves we
come back we just need two different J
but it's still quite tricky so I want
you to think for a second I'll take a
minute you took the residency if you
like if that's all you have and all I
ask you to do is graph where would you
go in this as it turns out the question
gives you a lot more hints and it sort
of pushes you in a very particular
direction but I want you guys to work a
little harder you know a lot about how
to work with graphs life is now right
you know about different kinds of
actually don't spoil it okay so I want
you to turn to the person next to you
think about what could we know about
this that will help us get towards a
future future that for a minute
obviously they don't see the other
patient i'm sure i wouldn't get
otherwise okay that was a little i like
some suggestions not actual things that
you you might have started doing but
what are some suggestions for directions
we could start to head it that will
yield some interesting or useful
information to help us gratis it's just
as in Port Sebelius ok I propose I mean
I'm sorry usually do it like you know a
jury to do what literally do what I
understand sorry so what you mean is
differentiate is that yeah okay I'll see
you to do right and I love you to go
it's all French it was likewise okay
let's let's rewind a little bit so the
question is that so something that could
help us here is different you think it
is clearly just do it what's wrong with
all of you people I just I just know
what that looks like a great yeah
fantastic yep good so we know that they
are going to be for all the inverse trig
functions you've got to be careful with
domain interestingly tanimoto just how
to think about that guy why does he
exist
he's okay Louis's everywhere right
organizers however this guy over here
does not right and in order to have this
guy you need all of the pieces right
like you're part of its broken then the
whole thing is broken okay so just to
name is the funny one okay is there
anything else that would be useful yeah
it's even enough even an odd so I'm
looking for does this function have any
kind of symmetry that I can take
advantage of you guys know um most
functions if you just think about the
whole world of universal functions a bit
most functions do not know century
because it's a very very special
property but the questions you're going
to get any exam papers I kind of very
skewed towards having features like this
because this is a feature we want you to
recognize and so we assess it right well
two three can I get some more
suggestions please also you're talking
about identities where do you mean
another time if you if you i suture me
yep okay so i'll write this down first i
do ? now the reason i'm going to put a
question mark here is just for the sake
of this question because i know exactly
which question looks like i happen to
know that in this case we could go down
this alleyway it doesn't happen in this
particular case to give us much new site
however there's no reason why it can't
you can see what he's getting a tan
inverse of this and any of us have this
you're not to only think of it than CA
but these are kind of like ankles right
let's see if I gave to you fleshies if i
gave you tan inverse of one that's an
angle what is
it's powerful okay so tan inverse sine
inverse cos of us where you seen burgers
you should think are these are kind of
like ankles right now therefore if I've
got regular table here one of the things
I could do and in another question get
my people useful is I could takes 18 of
both sides particular both sides because
then you've got tan of a plus B or is
turn about prospects it's 10 a push to
be on line 1 minus okay now just in this
case and we'll see i'll show you why it
doesn't end up going into a useful in
this particular case what would 10 i'm
going to call this my name and i'm going
to call this one be what's turning it's
just going to be X what's to be looking
online denominator I have you see where
I'm going 1-10 8mb 10 a 10 B oh so you
see in this case in this case it happens
to not be very useful but in other cases
it is and then what you get is just you
can consider as an inverse function okay
like you'll have a can of something over
here and you have something else over
here you can work with okay but it's not
about it yes if you've given up on life
in volatile values you could if you
really have nothing else you can choose
don't judge a tank and poor point in
fact in fact I am going to take
advantage of that in a second i am going
to legitimately took a bit okay oh five
points there we're gonna use four of
them except for one of an efficient so
it's not to have more intense do you
think that's the most natural water to
go in for this particular function what
do you think is asleep
yeah I think domain first is probably
the way to go I probably got a symmetry
after that then I'm going to
differentiate that tells me something
about the gradient you actually don't
know because again I know what there's
something even look like usually
differentiating there's something
there's an obvious thing missing from
this list action is kind of under here
which is intersects me so it was mostly
cacophony really sorry thank you it just
says of course a particular value of
like loading points x equals 0 y equal 0
so usually we would like get this out
and then see the intercept or even use
to us okay as it happens in this
particular case they're gone well let's
see what happens okay so let's begin
window mean we already almost got
halfway there this guy's just for all
real alien X this one almost exists for
realizing X except for x equals 0 so
what I'm going to say is i'm going to
say X can be all real values except x
equals 0 okay so x equals here is the
only hole with my function I can eat
just everywhere else and that's it
that's all I need to say about domain
I'm going to have a discontinuity of
some color it could be an asset or
something like that we'll find out in a
minute symmetry okay uh is this going to
be an even function what would it mean
to be an even fight what's a definition
and then exit if we're very good so this
is the kind of thing we're expecting
right which is why if you've got even
powers like if things r squared that's
why this kind of thing happens because
everywhere you put in negative x
negative x whole square just becomes X
well right but when you have a look at
this and I don't really see anything
that matches even symmetry right however
what is F of negative x in this case
it's going to be like just going for a
straight substitution right it's going
to be tan inverse of X plus tan inverse
of maybe one of X that a lovely thing
about this is the reason why suit use a
crane to actually going is because we
know that the component bits Teddy verse
and ten vessel whatever they're on
functions right there on functions so
therefore 10 of 10 inverse of negative x
is negative 10 inverse of X and the same
thing happens here it is that- tell you
most of all earnings so i've got a
double negative which corresponds my
double positive here so this is new
evidence one so you can see if all your
pieces are odd for your pieces are hard
then your total thing will be on does
that make sense cool so I have
subsidiary now I know that there's this
discontinuity I know that I actually now
only need to graph one half is right and
then what I want to get the other half
I'll just do a reflection okay or a
rotation of hingham oil